Nearly 70% of people who visited the reef in 2015...
...say they made the trip to Australia to witness its beauty before it's gone.
Almost half of the reef's coral has vanished over the past three decades,...
...thanks to warming ocean temperatures, invasive species and coastal development.
And this year, it suffered the worst coral bleaching in recorded history.
One study estimated over 90% of the reef has been affected.
The Australian government thought the reef's dire state would drive tourists away,...
...but it's done the exact opposite.
That's great news for the multibillion-dollar tourism industry,...
...but it can be bad news for the reef itself.
This phenomenon is called last chance tourism,...
...and it happens all the time at vanishing destinations...
...like the Maldives and Galapagos Islands.